[Music]
good evening and welcome to the running
commentary our top story this week my
green screen is broken
in other news simons double half
marathon running attempts fundraiser has
just topped 1250 pounds a milestone
which Simon describes as pretty crazy to
be honest to prepare for his two half
marathons Simon has been training
extensively including a long run in
Oxford however in a repeat of 2013
Simon's efforts in Oxford do not go to
plan Simon Clarke reports so we start
off this running commentary with me
being in Oxford I stayed at friends last
night because last night I was here
giving them a talk so tonight I was
hearing some Peters my old college which
you can see behind me there's a gorgeous
place for a physics alumni event I
always hear giving a talk to other
people members of the college who are
studying physics and some other alumni
and I went quite well I got to buy a bow
tie in Oxford pretty much any excuse for
that really I must confess though I've
got very fond memories of Oxford at
night
perhaps the overwhelming crushing
academic pressure wasn't quite so
apparent
peaceful at night when there's when the
drunks would have gone
today I'm running ten miles and I am
gonna be taking you along with me
sirens walk I'm making my way down the
road doing lunges trying to slightly
open up my legs at to honey me bet I
know that you don't normally stretch
I generally I don't before a run but my
legs just feel particularly tight so how
to take them sorry I mapped out a route
on my phone which is probably more than
ten miles I didn't I didn't finish it I
just could put the first half no like I
looks about right so this might actually
end up running a half marathon by a
prison fill a bit nervous about this one
for some reason doesn't you know why
last were you wasn't even last week it
was this Monday this is so did it we
just sort of started and didn't stop
until I reached the end silly as that
sounds just got to do that again ha all
right we go
[Music]
but see malson feel good I can feel the
muscles in my legs right last g7 the
fast run high I can feel how my mice
technique has been changing just coming
up into University Park it's nice to
walk here all the time when I was an
undergrad Wow look how high the river is
I've realized that by this training
Jesus I realize those part of this
training over basically we're taking in
all the key landmarks like cities from
my life all right Karen enough Bristol
Oxford I just got a scheduler trip so
access it now okay serious
[Music]
three miles in pissing down rain my cars
are really tight I think I'm feeling the
effects are going so fast on that last
run not sure I should go the whole
distance on this cuz I feel like I might
injure myself still just doing laps
around University parks it's very nice
okay I've done something that I not done
any of my training runs up until now and
I slowed to a walk because my carves
after I recorded that clip suddenly
really tightened up so I want to see if
I walked like a kilometer safe that's
gonna loosen them out I can keep running
if not annoying then I have to call this
one here that thing is also active
really looking forward to this one it's
like nice environment all around me and
I refer enjoyed the last one when I was
on the flat and this is almost entirely
on the flat I was just
I'm not reaping the issues I sowed my
last my mind I was just irresponsible so
yeah these are tight lesson learned I
guess yep I'm calling it really tight I
just tried walking for like having like
five minutes and then start it around no
this isn't happening
really really annoyed at myself for
letting me do that really fast around
the other day I think there's a hole it
might be too I think there's at least
one week in hand and the training regime
so I think what I'm gonna do is just
call it here walk back which is gonna be
another like for cash and basically
carry on this week as it says on the
schedule and then oh wow and then do a
long one this one next week so do do 9
miles next week so 10 miles next next
weekend then 11 the one after that and I
think that actually takes me right up to
the race reaping what you sow Simon look
put the footage of me being really
pleased with myself after the last run
yeah hope you're happy time I mean not
now in other news one particular day
this week
Simon attempted to go for a run but did
not in fact
said he just bled Simon Clark reports so
I I slightly screwed the pooch today
today on my schedule was a five-mile run
I was gonna do it I was actually looking
forward to doing and getting cut back
into it took two days off after I
crapped I've the weekend and yeah I was
looking forward to running and then I
forgot that I'm giving blood today I
signed up to donate ages ago
and by the time I'd remembered I
wouldn't have had enough time to run
beforehand
and I just I didn't feel like we running
off the missing a pint of blood is a
probably a very sensible idea so I think
I'm going to have to skip today's one
and move it to tomorrow which is it's
annoying so they run out off the
stickers for like regular donations so
apparently my mum gave blood today had
actually fallen out of the habit of
giving blood whilst I was doing the PhD
so quite glad to be getting back on it
then that's my
seventh or eighth donation now in total
so it's a good thing to do cost you
nothing but from like half an hour B
time
I'm gonna give you biscuits that isn't
the end of the day though because I've
actually got to write I need to go to
London can they're giving a talk man
ended up moans catch the train anyway
right I'm in London to give a talk at
the each new space this is the first day
of Eid duquan which I'd never been to
before it's like a mini conference I
happen to the for VidCon especially
about YouTube educators and I'm giving a
talk about moving from academia to so
out again
okay so I've been to the YouTube space a
bunch of times quite familiar with this
I've never been given the green room
treatment before so this is the green
room
it looks like Google built it but look
down here goodie bags I don't think I've
ever been given a speaker goodie bag
before sorry
that's may be really embarrassing if
they're not ask me for me but also wines
which I can't drink because of blood a
makeup area and the reminder to inna oh
wait let's backwards to tune wow it's
really resonant a la also in the bottom
here there's obviously a toilet and
sinks so that would really well a lot of
people came up and said nice things
afterwards including people who like I
really respect in the industry like
Philip from Kurt's cos act yes I realize
this isn't about running it's just like
I was meant to run today and I was like
what I should blog and then this this
happened and then this happened so I
thought I just include this I like
vlogging and I miss it alright this is
just an excuse to vlog anyway we're not
gonna go tomorrow where I'm gonna do
more stuff about edgy calm but I also
need to sneak in a run so over to
feature Simon now okay so it's tomorrow
wait a couple of hours past I went to
bed at about 5:00 last night because I
wants to get this video out about civics
gathering storm it's just got a really
impressive giant climate change mechanic
but it's a bit longer to finish than I
expected so yeah once but at 5:00 it's
currently about 10:00 in the morning and
I'm not going to add you Kahn today I'm
really annoyed about those really
portable bar they've got to get a video
up tomorrow and I didn't think the whole
morning because I gotta like nine this
this week's just been very frustrating
like later things are bunched up having
to get everything done want to get done
I couldn't afford to miss a run high
knee tied at the sofa yeah anyway in an
attempt to do at least one thing in my
life right I am now doing four to five
miles and a responsibly slow-paced not
gonna knock myself out running my legs
get it done
man this is boring when you do it slowly
this is so boring
let me go fast
oh come on on board
I was just sorry okay
oh that's stunning that was really
boring I know I needed to do that and I
know I needed to do it slow and my legs
definitely nowhere near as dead is
normal for it like I was tight and it's
nice psychological it's not over you
have to give 150 percent every time the
man of all the parts of this training I
never thought I'd struggle with forcing
myself to take it take it easy like
Ashley forcing myself to take a break
and go upstate is apparently just not
something I can do well did it today so
that's progress next time boys
next time Simon went on one additional
run this week but only recorded one
video during of his feet good job Simon
returning to the JustGiving page
Simon's original goal of 500 pounds and
his stretch goal of 1,000 pounds
although completely smashed this week
meaning that he will run the half
marathons in a costume the top donator
Rebecca Baldwin seeded the right to
choose the costume to Simon's father who
decided that Simon will run as Captain
climate change
however if everybody watching this video
approximately 10,000 people were to
donate just one pound we would raise
well over 10,000 pounds for charity
being able to give 5,000 pounds to each
of the two charities saving species from
extinction and kicking cancer in the
butt would be a monumental feat so if
you have just one pound or more or one
of your local currencies I'm not
particularly fussed please do go to the
link in the description to the Just
Giving page and donate as generously as
you're able to it will make a massive
difference to the two charities that
Simon is fundraising for that's all for
this week thank you very much for
watching and we'll be back with in a few
days with further misadventures of
Simon's running good evening
[Music]
boy is that hot
yep either type yeah